[Music]
what is the craziest
ingredient that you've ever eaten
ingredients in a food
cilantro shit's crazy [ __ ] sound tastes
like soap
craziest ingredients gradient not even
like the actual thing that i'm eating i
mean i guess
that is an ingredient too anything
fermented fermented soy beans fermented
tofu
vintage shark fermented shark that's
what it was in iceland
blue cheese yeah i'm vietnamese we put
fish sauce in everything so
uh live octopus hmm
limelock is pretty nuts is that an is
that an ingredient or you're just eating
it though
i mean technically it's an ingredient in
order to make live octopus
you need live octopus didn't we like i
mean jk party
had us eat the craziest [ __ ] like wasn't
it like canned snake or something
didn't we eat that once yeah like worms
uh what
else yeah like uh the [ __ ] i don't
know we had so much crazy [ __ ]
we yeah we ate a lot of crazy [ __ ]
that's why i'm like i don't know what's
crazy anymore
[ __ ] stinky tofu is crazy that's
pretty crazy that's totally food that's
not a crazy ingredient no it's [ __ ]
true what if i said
that there is food in this world that
contains things that
wouldn't be classified as safe for human
consumption
i heard that they use a clay in some
like yes along that line yes okay yeah
so a german baker
has who's been selling cookies for the
past two decades and he's been making it
like this for two decades he's recently
been
uh been uh there's a court order
basically telling him he can't sell his
cookies
as they are anymore he needs to modify
his recipe oh what if it's good though
or cease
uh apparently it's good because people
keep buying it uh
so the secret ingredient that uh the
government of german
germany is preventing him from using now
is
he spit what oh you want to guess
plastic
uh no plastic dandruff well he did say
it's along the lines of dirt like clay
right
you wouldn't assume that it's safe for
human consumption
but apparently you can't i think it's
dirt metal shavings close
that's pretty close closer uh yeah then
sand sand dust bunnies
oh my god that reminds me our friend our
friend recently told us that when he was
a kid
he used to go up to like trees that had
like the soft kind of wood and just eat
it like the bark you're just like you
call it chicken he was like it tastes
like chicken you just started like
eating it is this ak
i'm not naming names
[Laughter]
perfect people people from fredro did
the whole time
you're gonna explain what fredro i want
to try a woodchip cookie
all right how did they discover that he
was using this ingredient though
uh so long story short uh back in 2004
he started writing his ingredients list
out on the packaging
uh on his biscuits and he actually wrote
it
uh to let people know that he's using
sawdust and sawdust
and historically it has been used as a
filler so
uh so in times of poverty or whatever
that you didn't have enough flour
the people would put sawdust in in order
to create more
like uh thickness right it is fluffy it
is very fluffy yeah and so they're
saying that it mixes
right into a flower you wouldn't be able
to tell how many years ago was that
being
because maybe that the people in that
region like
they're like superheroes 1700s oh [ __ ]
basically seventeen hundreds yeah
seventeen oh seventeen hundreds yeah did
i say that
that's what i heard okay yeah seventeen
hundred yes so it it's definitely
historical
uh in fact that people saw dust uh to
bake and to create
uh goods whether they were low on flour
yes
so but he's only been doing it since
2000 yeah he opened up his bakery
since the early 2000s i have heard too
like in those times or i don't know the
year but like in
poverty times that people would even
boil rocks
to like get like flavor something out of
it minerals or something yeah minerals
yeah yeah have you heard of mississippi
mud pie no what is that so people
in that area have they used a red clay
there and some other
like cuisine because they had an iron
deficiency
so then they that's how they found like
i guess
i don't know maybe the body just like
needs certain foods so it goes i need
that [ __ ] you'll hear that
from like pregnant women uh when they're
malnourished
they start having these random cravings
and one would be like
dirt yeah laundry detergent oh yeah
laundry detergent
what kind of what kind of goodness is
smell it and you're like i need that for
my baby wow
i don't know that's good yeah i heard
kids even like when they're
on the playground they're just playing
around like they'll figure out like oh i
need to eat this right now because
like just they just know that their body
is like nourishing something
on the monkey bars i love licking my
hands you were
you probably need iron or iron
i don't know but yeah so back to this
baker
uh he so he's always included the
ingredient
on the packaging in 2004 he decided to
write to the city
that this is what he does using sawdust
to cook so he told on himself
for like 20 years already but then the
government's like finally i'll get to it
they didn't receive that he received no
answer the government just didn't care
or for whatever reasons they he
didn't get a response like we have
bigger problems true
what prompted him to even need to do
this i think he knew
that it was weird it's like hey i'm
doing something that most bakers don't
do i'm using
sawdust as a filler and maybe he thinks
personally thinks that it
tastes better or has a better you know
texture
or whatever so he just wanted to be open
about it and not get in trouble
and then out of nowhere in 2017 at after
a routine
examination of the biscuit uh the court
has now decided to ban his sales um
unless he decides to change his recipe
did they give a uh
a reasoning were they like this is bad
for you this is the
exact reasoning these cookies must not
be allowed into the food chain because
they are not
safe and are objectively seen not fit
for human consumption
that just sounds like an emotional
reaction because has anyone reported
any sort of symptoms after consuming
these cookies it seems like he's been
scotch-free like for 20 years
and then out of nowhere they're like the
government's like not cool
and i mean if he's using like home depot
chemically treated lumber
that's probably not a good idea i don't
know i don't know
but if he went and like chopped his own
[ __ ] special german oak or whatever
the
[ __ ] they have out there still 20 years
no one's
gone after him it was because government
is lazy
oh i mean a person like a person you
know oh yeah
yeah it could be one of those things
where like he's using old technology and
he's cooking the old way
and then now like i don't know city
halls a bunch of new people
so they're just going by the books and
then
and they don't understand the old
history so they don't even know how to
be flexible they just go what saw this
hell no are you kidding me
it's the youngins coming into the
government uh buildings but there's also
old ingredients that are harmful that we
used in history that
they're like you shouldn't be cooking
like this no more dude [ __ ] lead in
it and everyone's getting
makeup yeah i do wonder what the health
ramifications are of sawdust for them to
know it's probably like that
the court even said it isn't even used
in industrial animal feed sectors so
even animals don't eat sawdust why would
you feed it to humans and that's
delicious
apparently where are people gonna get
their dust biscuits from i know
i'm glad they're like making them take
it out i have no
official picture from the like they
didn't even identify the baker
but yeah but this is what's happening
it's like a unprecedented
like ruling in germany uh it seems like
it's in a very small
town it sounds very small where is it
for him
because if it's not harmful i don't know
like there are a lot of harmful things
that are
okay in our market like corn oil
vegetable
oil things like that corn syrup is
pretty bad uh so the baker claims that
in the sawdust there are uh there well
it's
quote microbiological is what he's using
using to describe sawdust
um and that it gives the cookies an
herbal product
or it is a herbal product woodsy yeah
similar to bran is this what he's then
use bran
yeah yeah i always say like maybe it's
not a big deal right give yourself the
answer
if you think about how cinnamon is like
you know cinnamon's like
bark right and then they shave that [ __ ]
down
yeah yeah and then you shave it into
small little
dusty parts and then you use that
like metal and then i was like uh
well there's gold flakes that people eat
because the gold is a metal
so i'm like yeah or like i don't know
like um
star and nice or any herb that's kind of
like a
i don't know like you just grind it yeah
you grind it up yeah it is kind of woody
what do you think is more difficult the
cinnamon challenge or the sawdust
challenge
oh [ __ ] your lungs are good
you get splinters yeah i do wonder if
cinnamon can give you uh
cancer the same way sawdust can so it
doesn't give you cancer where did you
get this from
us it's highly cancerous you mean like
when you breathe it in
yeah yeah okay it was like for eating i
was like then they haven't because the
cinnamon challenge
has you breathing in a [ __ ] ton of
cinnamon at once yeah
so sawdust is incredibly what's
cancerous about it
people who work with uh sawdust or like
wood a lot they
but isn't it because they're not working
with like natural wood they're working
with like
actual natural wood is incredibly bad
for your lungs
incredibly is that mesothelioma stuff
what's mesothelioma i always see these
[ __ ] commercials
no i've only heard it from the
commercials yeah because they're like
uh when we were on our flight like one
of the commercials was like a law firm
that only focuses on mesothelioma cancer
like patients apparently it's cancer i
don't know but all the images were from
people in construction and working oh
that might be the
lumberjacks i don't know so maybe it's
good that these
forests are burning [ __ ] them dude
cancer when they smoke the lumber it
smells so good though
it does smell good yeah but you like the
smell of
wood cuttings like fresh cut wood yeah
oh yeah i guess it's good like cedar and
like it smells good
it does i could smell it no but
with all those fires too though like all
that soot that happens
and it just covers the entire city
that's it's very dangerous for you too
we
looked up on how to clean it because
they're live or dead they suck
let's give it all cheese yeah let's get
rid of the trees stop planting trees we
don't want any more trees to be they're
ruining our planet yeah
they give us cancer yeah you see i
evolved
plants they helped us breathe too how
about vines
like let's just replace the trees with
something else you can all swing on
vines
wait where did vines blueberry blinds i
don't know on anything
on anything oh is that like they're
growing on the trees and that's how they
hit no no from the ground
no i mean yeah but like they go on the
tree they don't have they can crawl on
anything
so it's like no but the hanging vines
though what i'm talking about yeah they
they came from the ground but they went
up the tree and then
they fell down yeah yeah yeah like
tarzan vines
my house is covered in vines i [ __ ]
hate it would you guys eat sawdust
cookies yeah hell yeah i've been wanting
to as soon as i heard about it if i was
there
i would try for one's not gonna give me
cancer true
oh like try it like just one time yeah
yeah just to give it a shot like i do
most things once even if it's bad for me
nice i'd even try dookie if everyone did
it
if everyone is doing that's gross
[Music]
do